one guy that's been linked to the
pittsburgh steelers is jj
watt just because he's got two brothers
playing for the team peter king makes a
great point though it could be jj watt
doesn't want to overshadow his brother
tj and that's what would happen
if jj comes to pittsburgh what we've
heard so far
jj watts seriously interested in the
browns now we couple that
with jj watts very cryptic tweet
from wednesday late morning early
afternoon depending upon your time zone
that free agency is wild he doesn't say
why it's wild he doesn't say what's wild
about it what's so wild about me he
doesn't say any of that
all he says is it's wild is it wild
because they're beating a path to his
door
with eight figure per year offers
probably not
he's probably saying it's wild because
he's been on the market
for five days he's a three-time
defensive player of the year
a future hall of famer they should be
lining up
with significant offers and they're not
he's the
john travolta meme from pulp fiction
looking around wondering where the hell
all the money is
that may be why it's wild and what he
may be learning
is what we first suspected on friday
that 33 day head start
to the open market doesn't matter
because it may not be until 33 hours
before free agency opens
that we know what the salary cap is and
jj watt at his current age
and skill level falls into that category
of veteran players who are going to be
getting less than what they would have
gotten in a
normal year this is anything but a
normal year this is a year where you're
going to get squeezed if you're in the
middle
j.j watts in the middle and he's going
to get squeezed and even the browns who
have cap space
why would you commit a specific number
now
to jj watt because how do you even begin
to finalize your budget
you know in a normal year the owners are
told in december
what the salary cap likely will be for
the next year
and then it's finalized at some point
late february
before the end of the free agency
not free agency but the franchise tag
designation period because the franchise
tag is tied to the salary cap
that's usually the latest we know what
it is we may not know what it is
how can you make that budget how can you
figure out how much cash to hold back
how much cash to invest how much you can
pay
jj watt even if you're a team that has
plenty of cap space
you have to earmark all of it for what
you plan to do
by way of spending and the other factor
for these teams
that in a normal year i didn't do the
air quotes normal year
isn't a factor is their money is down
they're not swimming in cash like they
usually are somebody suggested to me
recently
i don't know if this was peter king
earlier on pft live i think it may have
been i talk to so many different people
it all starts to blend together oh and
i'm old and i'm forgetful
75 million per team in losses from
last year 75 million it's not
money falling out of the sky like it
usually is that's another reason to wait
that's another reason to structure a
contract that
maybe has significant guaranteed money
for j.j watt but he doesn't get any of
it
until september when the tv deals start
to pay off for 2021 or when
box office money starts showing up so
i think that jj watt regards the
situation as wild
primarily because it's not what he
thought
it would be and isn't that really the
definition of wild
it's something completely different than
what i thought it would be
and for j.j watt that's exactly what
it is
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc sports